but let's start with a big argument at
the heart of positive populism the
president put it clearly the other week
after years and years of building up
other countries we are finally building
up our country standing up for our jobs
our workers and standing up for our
dignity the Forgotten men and women of
America will never ever be forgotten
again you were forgotten exactly now
what is interesting is that Donald Trump
has so completely reshaped politics that
the 2020 Democrats are trying to copy
him by claiming the mantle of populism
they're the real populist they said at
their last debate Trump has only helped
the rich Donald Trump is part of a
corrupt rigged system that has helped
the wealthy and the well-connected and
kicked dirt in the faces of everyone
else for the last three years we've
watched Donald Trump it working people
against each other black versus white
citizen versus immigrant and why so that
the wealthy and the powerful he
represents can hold the American Dream
hostage from everyone else we're looking
at someone who passed the tax bill
benefiting the top one percent and the
biggest corporations in this country
when he said he would help working
families oh my gosh it's exhausting
isn't it now this is the Democrats
central claim Donald Trump has broken
his promise to help working Americans
he's not a real populist his policies
have only helped the rich honestly these
are lies lies lies here are the facts
the facts the facts between 2016 and
2018 corporate profits rose by two
hundred and twenty billion dollars while
workers earnings went up by almost a
trillion dollars four times more the
Democrats also say Trump is just
continuing what Obama started but the
facts show this is a complete lie to
workers earnings increased by 42% more
during President Trump's first two years
in office than in Obama's last two there
was a massive and almost instant jump a
turnaround that has destroyed the left's
economic argument because it is a
perfect
case of what pro growth Pro Enterprise
economics can do yes it's true that
corporate tax cuts and deregulation
helped businesses but who do you think
actually creates jobs and pays wages
helping business is the way you help
workers let me explain how it works for
the economically illiterate Democrats
and their idiotic Stooges in the
establishment state media lower taxes
and less regulation give businesses the
confidence to invest that means more
innovation and higher worker
productivity that means more jobs are
created and workers are paid more
because they are producing more on jobs
the latest report showed 164 thousand
jobs were added bringing the labor force
to almost 163 million a new all-time
record with President Trump we've seen
the lowest unemployment in 50 years on
the lowest on record for
african-american and Hispanic workers on
workers pay the latest data on employee
compensation showed that earnings rose
4.5% in 2017 and 5% last year even
higher than previously reported and way
ahead of inflation but the best news is
on low-income workers President Trump is
specifically delivering on the promises
he made to the Forgotten men and women
who in 2016
revolted against an establishment that
punished them for decades in the name of
elitist dogma like open borders free
trade and globalization in the Trump
economy incomes are rising fastest for
the lowest paid look at this hourly pay
growth for the bottom 25% has outpaced
that of higher earners every month of
the Trump presidency and in blue-collar
industries like mining construction and
transportation we're seeing wage growth
far exceed what we saw under obama's
second-term plus with president Trump's
revitalization of manufacturing which
all the establishment experts said was
impossible by the way jobs are coming
back in numbers we haven't seen for
decades last year's game of 264 thousand
manufacturing jobs was the highest since
1997 the facts
demonstrate conclusively that working
Americans are the winners in the Trump
economy yes he is the real populist and
it's the Democrats who are fake they
want to reverse the Trump tax cuts and
deregulation that would reverse the
Trump job gains and earnings rise they
want to make energy more expensive ask
president macron in France what working
people think of that he still got
protests in the streets over green
policies that are mild compared to what
these Democrats want here and of course
all of them want a massive expansion in
government paid for by you that's not
just a tax grab it's a power grab as
well that's the deep reason all these
Democrats are fake populist populism is
about power to the people the left are
about taking power away from people and
giving it to their government but
there's one more argument that's a
complete line we need to demolish that
too this one comes not from the left but
from there never trumpets and the
Republican establishment they say well
Donald Trump may have a good economy but
that's just because of traditional
conservative policy where he's moved
away from Republican orthodoxy like on
trade in China it's been a disaster
again this is total BS as we keep
telling you tariffs work they worked on
the border with Mexico and are working
with China the way the critics talk
you'd think our entire economy was
dependent on China but remember in 2018
imports from China were just 2.7 percent
of our economy and exports to China just
naught point nine percent look there's
no doubt that the trade war with China
has introduced economic uncertainty and
that is never a good thing as we saw
last week the Democrats and the
establishment state media are hyping up
a recession because they think it's the
best way to get rid of a president they
despise here's what newly-minted never
Trump Anthony scare Moochie has been
saying that any passing TV camera what
he's done on the trade situation has
totally and completely destabilized the
global economy
and it forget about the farmers for a
second I'm very sympathetic to them but
it's hurting them
but it's hurting the entire capital
markets system yeah I forget about the
farmers there you have it he just gave
the game away another fake populist
unbelievably he actually wrote a book
called the blue collar president and
came on this show to promote it but now
we see which side he's really on the
Wall Street wheeler dealers in the what
did he call it capital market system who
for decades have screwed the American
worker to make themselves rich
especially over China so it is highly
revealing that these elitist
globalization ideologues are dumping on
Trump just at the moment when his
populist trade policies are starting to
work for 50 years China was moving
inexorably towards its stated aim of
toppling America as the world's economic
and military superpower by 2049 not
least by cheating on trade rules and
stealing technology now thanks to
President Trump
China is reeling as a direct result of
the Trump terrace manufacturers are
moving supply chains out of China
Manufacturing was the foundation of
China's rise and it's crumbling before
our eyes China's economic growth has
slumped to the lowest in nearly 30 years
the establishment critics say that well
our growth is down to yes the latest
number was 2.1 percent but that was
higher than anyone expected and just
compare it to what's going on elsewhere
in the world
EU growth in the same period was less
than half as much nor 2.8 percent and
their unemployment rate was 7.5 percent
they thought that was good it was down
slightly but it's more than twice as
high as ours the establishment loved to
regurgitate their tired talking points
about consumers paying for the trade war
but they are idiotically short-sighted
they don't take account of the costs to
our society and our economy of shipping
jobs to China so they can ship cheap
products back here we had a fantastic
debate on this on deep dive last week
honestly it's worth signing up to fox
nation just for this here's a clip the
market price of that cheap t-shirt and
that cheap TV does not include the
devastation of that town in Iowa which
the government and taxpayers have to pay
for
ways through welfare payments or dealing
with the opioids or whatever it is let
me finish right so you got that going on
there's a huge set of social and
economic costs that are not included in
the price of that cheap t-shirt all I'm
saying is you include it in the price so
it's a real price by putting a massive
tariff on any t-shirt that is made
outside the country so that it then is
equal and then you might as well make it
here because it's not going to be any
cheaper if you import it that would be
my policy if you want to sell it in
America you can damn well make it in
America on China here's what I wrote in
my book positive populism last year it's
time for a complete economic boycott of
China all US companies in China should
pull out and no new investment should be
made the establishment just don't get
the historic geo strategic turnaround
that trump tariffs are delivering here's
what to ask the never Trump errs and the
conservative ideologues and the
establishment if you don't like what
President Trump is doing on trade what's
your alternative what's your plan to
stop China cheating us what's your plan
to stop China beating us these Trump
tariffs are the first thing in 50 years
that have got China's attention and they
are reshaping the global economy to
America's advantage now all that would
be put at risk of course by this man on
the defining issue of our age the
Democrats seem hell-bent on nominating
someone for president who is totally
compromised by our greatest enemy China
as we have often shown you Joe Biden
took over a billion dollars in bribes
from the authoritarian Chinese regime in
the form of payments the Biden family
businesses hashtag Joe China in 2016 by
contrast we saw once again the true
genius of this country America elected
as president the only person who was
prepared to confront its greatest
challenge President Trump is not just
the real populist he's the really
successful populist where he's followed
through
conservator canned or mixed tax cuts and
deregulation the results have been great
especially for working Americans but
where the president has fought his own
instincts on Trade and China the results
have been transformational and historic
that is positive populism in action tell
me what you think at Steve Hilton X and
that next rev fnc